hi everyone I'm Lea Miller one of
Samuels students and this is my mom
Cheryl hi so recently me and my mom
completed on our first buy refurbish
refinance deal day we've documented the
whole process of the refurb so you can
see how we go from a two bit house to a
five bed house so we stood outside our
first buy refurbish refinance project
we've not logging picked up the keys and
our builders just come round to sort of
give us an idea of the schedule of works
and what needs to do in so we started
off with a two bird house which has two
reception rooms and all of the rooms
were quite big so we've managed to split
one of the bedrooms and then we've
turned the bottom reception rooms into
bedrooms so this is the first room and
they actually used to use this as a
publisher's hence why there's like all
the shelves so what we're gonna do in
here is turn this into the probably the
biggest bedroom and we're gonna put a
fitted wardrobe here and a desk over
here and then we'll have a nice bed just
in the corner sort of here but it's a
really like nice-sized room
so we're gonna start well I'm one day
they're gonna start stripping it all
back and restarting the whole thing for
the second bedroom this is going to be
the only bedroom with an ensuite so this
was like a kind of last-minute decision
to put an ensuite in there and we just
thought because we've got the space to
do it from the kitchen that we can now
put an ensuite in there so this is the
second room
at the minute it's really kind of open
plan but what we're gonna do is put
stood wall from here going all the way
down to create another corridor and then
we're gonna put the door here to create
the second bedroom we're going to put
the on Suites in this space here so
going into the kitchen because this wall
has been made really wide and it doesn't
need to be that wide so to make
most of the space we're going to use
that for the ensuite and then the new
window is going to go over there we've
got a some ventilation and also a fire
escape from the downstairs room as well
so for the kitchen we are going to use
the same cupboards and we're just going
to paint them a nice gray color because
they're in quite good condition so you
don't need to like get a whole new
kitchen so we're actually gonna keep the
existing kitchen the kitchen units
because they're quite new this was like
a new extension and our builder who's
also the chippy is going to just
reconfigure the kitchen with the
existing units and if we can't we'll put
two of them's and two fridges in because
it's five tenants which is quite a lot
of people we're going to put a breakfast
bar in there and then have some fridge
freezers under the counters say yeah
they're all gonna have their own fridge
freezer so they've all got their own
space so hopefully there won't be any
arguments that there's an ensuite for
there you can also use a bifold shower
door off of the bedroom it doesn't need
to be a proper does it yeah so obviously
that ensuite from that first room is
going to come into here probably two
around kind of like there as it's kind
of length and then we're gonna have a
second wet room made off the kitchen
close to that door where you're standing
so we're second wet room there and then
the rest of the space is going to be
kitchen and breakfast bar so breakfast
bar where the tenants can fit and watch
the TV because the rooms are so big we
don't really need a communal area as
such so the kitchen is working fine as a
communal area so if we put a TV in there
and a dining table so they can all eat
and chill there together that should be
fine
so this but the family bathroom is here
this bathroom is actually really
so we're actually going to create
separate wet rooms in here for the
tenants they're going to be quite big
the boilers in there and we can still
accommodate it so each tenant although
there won't all be on Suites up here
each tenant will have their own private
bathroom so that's basically the
alternative solution that we've gone for
to try to keep costs down so by not
creating ensuite in each of the rooms
and our build is quite creative so he
was able to find a way that we can
basically have the whole bathroom on one
shower tray so we have the shower tray
and then a warm toilet and then a wall
hung basin as well
well it's quite good because I think
it's nicer that they can all have their
own bathroom instead of having to share
this this room at the front is like an
l-shaped room and I guess this is the
room that kind of really adds the value
because this room has two windows and
it's quite big and it has two openings
so we spoke to the HMO officer and he
measured up with us and said that we
would be able to split it into two
bedrooms so that's how we created the
fifth bedroom so it's gonna be split I'm
kind of like down the middle and we're
gonna take this down this is just a tall
so we're going to remove this and then
we'll kind of recreate that openings to
get to what will still be two doubles
bedrooms in this that will have their
own windows so we'll just move the
radiators around slightly obviously
we're changing the windows anyway
because we need to get better glazing in
and again they'll both have fitted
wardrobes and a fitted desk and shelves
yeah that one might be initiative for
escape
so this room's really straightforward so
they'll just rip everything back get rid
of the floor in put wardrobe bed and
desk in and get up see redecorate it and
paint the things like that so the garden
is a bit of a mess there is actually
like a random shed over here it's
obviously all really overgrown but it is
a decent size and for five tenants once
it's all kind of done and like
everything's cleared out we're gonna put
a few benches out and things like that
so they can have somewhere to chill okay
guys so that was part one of our refurb
project there will be another two videos
so in the next video
you can see the sort of process and how
it's all coming along and then for the
final video you'll see the finished
results if you like this video be sure
to give it a thumbs up and comment down
below and don't forget to subscribe to
Sam Mills awesome YouTube channel and
I'll see you next time bye
you